[Musique]
à
nous tout c'est un collectif qui lutte
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles
les militants dans chaque ville vont
mettre en place des actions de type
distribution de furlan tôt m ou des
départs groupés pour la marche qu'on
vous fait à chaque mois de chaque mois
de novembre
[Musique]
on entend beaucoup dire mais c'est bon
en france
il ya plus de problème de ce type il ya
des pays où c'est beaucoup plus grave
etc mais quand on regarde les chiffres
au final ils sont importants voilà on a
quand même encore 102 féminicide là
cette année pour l'instant les gens
n'ont pas conscience en fait de
l'importance de ces violences là encore
en france donc c'est important voilà de
faire prendre conscience de ça et que du
coup derrière ça
incite à ce que soient mises en place
des politiques publiques et les budgets
nécessaires qu'ils soient mises en place
pour pour régler ces problèmes
[Musique]
via un numéro qui est joignable 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 c'est le 39
19 donc ça c'est vrai aussi bien pour
les personnes qui sont victimes que pour
les personnes qui peuvent être dans le
voisinage qui entendent eux
et personne proche en fait qui veulent
savoir quoi faire pour pour aider dans
ces cas là par contre si la personne est
vraiment en situation de danger imminent
c'est le 17 qu'il faut appeler un seuil
et la police et puis sinon il ya le
numéro 0 800 05 95 95 ces viols femmes
informations